this is film courage episode number 147
my name is David Brent I I don't you
know I'm so you up so you see you
jumping in their care night you know I I
forgot I was being cute up here today
you can find our archives on itunes film
curse calm la talk radio com in movie
garage and my name is Karen warden you
know I was just about to throw in
something spontaneous that I love it
when you opened the show we almost
didn't open the show look this is why I
try not to open the show but you know I
have to ask you David what what was your
favorite video game growing up what my
favorite you know I I'm a big NBA live
person no you know I'm a basketball fan
and I used to play NBA Live and then
you're already like thinking what you
don't even know what NBA Live is well
I'm not sports fan but I remember what I
used to play I had a Texas Instrument I
know it it's a long time ago and I used
to play Qbert and I usually love cuber
yeah like I used to love Cuba I mean
that's really cool but I'm trying I'm
trying to think of playing on the Texas
Instruments I'm not familiar with that
yeah it had like a little plug in you
know joystick and had its own local
console and you would plug it into your
TV and you know but we can play it that
way so it was very cool well our guest
today have made a film generating lots
of talk in the indie gaming community
and that's a long ways off from Qbert or
pole position or super mario brothers
lizanne pezzo and James sworsky writers
directors editors and cinematographers
for one of this year's sundance films
entitled indie game the movie join us
via telephone indie game the movie
follows the dramatic journeys of indie
game developers as they create games and
release those works in themselves to the
world introverted and obsessed with
their game projects these developers
divulge information about the beginnings
of their creativity and their upbringing
lizanne and James successfully raise
large sums of money in to Kickstarter
campaigns one in the summer of two
thousand ten or they exceeded their
$15,000 goal by raising over
twenty-three thousand dollars and in
June of 2011 they reached out to the
again through Kickstarter with another
pre-order campaign to help with
finishing cost of the film and the
response was overwhelming this time the
gaming community came through again and
they reached their 35 thousand dollar
goal in just over 24 hours which I just
can't believe the campaign closed with
over two hundred percent of its goal
over 71,000 dollars enlisting the help
of nearly 1,600 backers welcome via
telephone miss Lee's on pojo and mr.
James Swersky welcome guys hi hi hey hey
hey great no we haven't seen the entire
film but the trailers and the the
various interviews that we've seen look
incredible and you know the footage
looks amazing and the story is
intriguing so this is one of our 2012
must-sees absolutely in the music there
too i we like we had to sneak in as much
of that music as we could for that
opening part there yum you can connect
with leanne on twitter at leas ampas oh
and James at James sworsky and also make
sure you follow indie game movie well
first off congrats on sundance it's a
thank you em using food and when do you
go when do you arrive there uh wheelie
Wednesday early early Wednesday morning
and then the film premieres on Friday
Friday night alright afternoon yeah
that'll be really the first time that an
audience will have seen the film that
will see it in the theater ourselves
there's pretty big yeah it's funny we
actually yesterday we did a count of how
many people have seen this film and we
counted about 35 people no it's like a
ridiculously small sample size of people
that were working with right now same so
far 35 out of 35 people liked it which
is good fun and so it'll be it'll be so
amazing to actually show it to you know
hundreds of people work you know I was
in over a thousand by the end of it yeah
so it should be should be awful no I
mean you guys are bursting on the scene
i Makee can you first take us back you
know when and how did you find out the
news about sundance
hmm oh we were actually showing the film
to a couple characters in the film there
they live in Santa Cruz California and
when we smell and in his wife and
another character was there at tommy
revenues and so we just shown in the
film like the day before and then we
were at a starbucks in santa cruz
downtown we're from Winnipeg so it's
lovely there and we were sitting in the
starbucks and we got the call and
there's very kind of surreal it was
surreal to get compliments about your
film from like people that watch 500
docks a year that was that was kind of
bizarre and kind of this typical like
cuz I've read stories of other side met
people you know hearing the news and
they talk about you know just getting
overwhelmed and inexplicably you know
breaking into tears and that's that's
kind of what we did so we're in a
Starbucks and we just ended up kind of
in the most you know respectful way
possible sobbing in the corner of it we
must have looked like freaks or like a
couple that's breaking up but it was
very setup of it and yes oh he was it
was isn't yeah amazing surreal
experience to have that happen if it
doesn't feel real even right now it
doesn't feel real but it will certainly
is really you know when you guys
submitted the film I mean did you have
any indication that you guys were going
to get into the festival you know
because we all know the only way to get
into Sundance is you have to know
somebody so who was the connection that
put you guys over the top was a Kevin
Smith oh there's no idea like we like
when we started this project our goals
were pretty humble all we want to do is
make a film and you that there was an
audience online because of the first
Kickstarter campaign and we thought we
were going to market it online and that
sort of where it would live and the idea
of festivals what didn't really become
president like present to us at all
until like maybe after we've done the
majority of shooting and we were editing
and we were like well you know maybe we
should try to debut this somewhere and
so we worked really hard and crunched
really hard to try to get it together
for the Toronto Film Festival which we
didn't get in go to
and that was a big rush that was a lot
of stress because you know everything is
sort of heightened at that point like
our goals were modest initially but
because there's been so much attention
about the film and people have gotten
really excited we thought oh well are we
doing ourselves a disservice by not
attempting to premiere at a festival
this is our first feature we you know we
haven't really done the festival circuit
or any of the sales stuff or anything
like that so yeah so we sort of
approached it are our expectations kind
of changed as we were making it I mean
did you guys almost not submit the
Sundance I mean did you almost say you
know what let's just forget the
festival's how close were you to that to
that end of the game uh pretty close
actually yeah like we were from Canada
and we kind of our initial like dream
premiere at one point in production what
was kind of uh we thought you know if
we're going to be able to do a big
premiere anywhere it would be Toronto
because we kind of have a little bit of
a home field advantage and they folk you
know feature Canadian content and we
kind of thought to ourselves you know if
we can't make it in Toronto well then
there's no way we can make it into
Sundance because you know it just you
know because Iran turn this down but
Toronto did see a different cause of
film and we kind of the film was just
getting better and better and and we
were encouraged to they said some
wonderful things about it and you know
they said it's great and they liked it
but it just doesn't fit this year it was
interesting it wasn't really ready like
we had been only editing it for like
less than three months when we showed
Toronto yeah and that like a sort of a
lesson in a way like you don't want to
show like that early of a cut to film
programmer because they might you know
just write you off because there's a lot
of work to do still on the film like
most films take months and months to cut
and really ours ended up taking you know
like an intense three months but then
like two months of polishing yeah but
but the whole strategy kind of just
right at the outset of this was we
wanted we knew that we had an audience
that wanted to see this film and we knew
that we can make a film that they would
really like but our main goal like our
ultimate goal was can we make a film
that not only they would cherish but
also that
broader audience could relate to and it
could resonate with and as the movie you
know kind of came to fruition and
started to evolve we started seeing that
movie that movie that perhaps other
people could relate to and we kind of
showed it around to a few people and it
seemed to like strike a chord with them
as well so it kind of gave us the
confidence to kind of pursue a festival
and to think that that would be that
would be a good way to go because we
always had self distribution kind of as
our base plan but we were kind of open
to this whole other world that we we
should give a shot and so kind of based
on that thinking we ended up submitting
to sundance yeah yeah yeah you know some
so many filmmakers believe that Sundance
is the golden ticket you know and many
base their distribution strategies
around a sundance premiere that never
happens you know what kind of
expectations do both do you have going
in here I think we're open to a lot of
things like we actually had sort of like
a whole distribution plan set up before
we found out in a self-organized tour
doing a lot of the amazing things that
Gary hustad has been the the creator of
objectified helvetica and urbanized he's
done incredible things on his own and we
totally took a page from him and took a
page from the indie game developers that
are in the film they do digital
distribution on their games and they're
doing incredibly well and so we had
devised a plan prior to Sunday's and
then Sundance happened and everything
sort of got put on hold so we're going
in there like thinking you know if we
can get a broadcast deal or something
that would be awesome but if things
don't suit these are goals of having
this online as fast as possible then we
may not go with those traditional type
deals there really a pen yeah like the
base thinking going into Sundance is
that we had this kind of self
distribution model that we were very
happy with but we know that there's a
whole bunch of opportunity that could
kind of either augmented or replace it
or just kind of propel the film 22
beyond what we think are sort of target
audiences or our niche audience because
the film is sort of an emotional journey
about people following their dreams
essentially that's what it is and I
think a lot of people even people who
aren't won't identify as gamers per se
will get something from it and so it's
reaching that broader audience that we
don't necessarily have the ability to do
and so if there's somebody or a group
that can do that that would be super
exciting at the same time if nothing
happens we're okay when you went in to
get these interviews from these various
developers what was sort of the essence
that you wanted to capture like what was
the main thing you wanted to take away
from each interview to kind of humanize
them or what was the thing that you
wanted to show I think we really want to
show what the creative experience is
like and being creators we know that
there are ups and downs and there are
moments and vulnerability and feeling
like you don't know what you're doing
but then there's also moments of
inspiration and being being able to get
intimate real interviews from people was
really important to us we spend a lot of
time with the people in the film we got
to know them over the series of like
months and getting their trust was a big
part of what we did we want to show them
we showed them stuff like we would cut
staff to show them like initially to say
you know we know what we're doing we're
going to treat your story with respect
and treat it well at the same time yeah
and when we when we show some stuff it
wasn't it wasn't so much to show them
where their story is going but it was
more like to prove ourselves actually to
say you know your incompetent hands like
we you know we're you know we're not
going to do with the service to your
story yeah yeah so we you know like like
all interviewers you do a ton of
research to research both you know what
you want the the person say we are film
is there's no narration or style is very
much getting people to speak honestly
and describe the experience so that we
don't necessarily need to use narration
and things like that so you you know you
create a question line to to get that
but also we were there a lot like
were really there during crucial moments
and and in those moments I think by that
time we felt really comfortable with
them and and comfortable enough that
they could describe what they were
feeling like in the moment and not feel
sort of reserved about it because you
know in the film like goes down
like things don't work out there in a
position where we are where they're on
the cusp of spending like you know two
years on something and then stuff
doesn't work out and it's devastating
and we were really lucky that they felt
comfortable not comfortable enough to
share that sort of disappointment and
those sort of things because if someone
was filming me right now going through
all this I would be incredibly guarded
well that was my next question because
now that you're further along in this
and you sort of have more riding on
everything you've gotten a ton of press
and you've had two very successful you
know Kickstarter campaigns and you're
going to sundance how are you handling
it I know you said it seemed surreal
earlier but sort of time wise
emotionally are you balancing another
job with all of this yeah no no no other
jobs for sure actually when we started
this we were naive enough to think that
we were going to be able to because we
did kind of commercial and corporate
work before we thought we can like bang
off corporate gigs in between some
shooting and all that stuff but no this
movie has completely taken over our
lives but then when in terms of the
Sundance prep and all that as soon as
it's like the Sun that's enough it
happened all of a sudden immediately
that day we got a thousand emails a
thousand plus emails and then the next
day you get like 800 and then 500 the
next day and it was yet completely crazy
and all these like really flattering
emails for people that you know we we
personally felt like we had no right to
talk to you in terms of like industry
industry of stuff and ranking and all
that stuff and it's a whole bunch of
like really nice emails and some like
opportunistic emails like I'm sure as
there's companies out there that send
you stuff too like every person news and
Sundance and so and then a whole bunch
of other just need opportunities and
three to four weeks since SNS
announcement that whole time that whole
period was spent sorting through those
emails and figuring out what we need to
pay attention to what what we don't need
to pay attention to and kind of figuring
out where the opportunity is in that and
just kind of organizing that stuff and I
think oh well it just one sec and I
think one of the things that had it
sorry knock at the door delivery sorry
about that matches he has knocked on the
door oh wow yeah so uh yeah so it
basically we had like tons of tons you
have like this huge laundry list of
things that you need to do in order to
get prepared for Sundance technical
things and promotional things and just
getting all your ducks in a row and all
like these thousand little things I
think had this wonderful effect of
distracting us from the effectiveness of
the actual situation so it felt it felt
numb like it had this wonderful numbing
effect and now that we actually have
taken care of everything and this
probably and it two days ago we finally
like cross the last thing off our list
it's all sinking in like that numbness
is wearing off and now it's not to be
excited and freaked out and all that
when you're caught up in the logistics
of like you know printing posters
talking the sales agents figuring out
whether you want to wear the sales
agents looking at contracts that all
seems really immediate and so like the
the feeling like feeling of knowing that
people are going to see our work for the
first time has sort of been in the back
burner but now it's becoming way more
present for sure no just just hearing
that I mean we're really humbled that
you you would answer our email I know
you know somehow film crews got through
didn't go to the spam filter did we
thank you for that yeah thank you well I
think it's interesting too because we're
all sort of we can read books and see
videos from experts on what to do to get
to that level but we don't know what to
do when it comes and I think that's
interesting that you've talked about how
it's been very numbing because there's
not really a roadmap for what to do when
that six
does come and I'm curious are there
things you can recommend to other people
who if they're listening now and are
going through it or if at some time they
do you know how do you prioritize those
emails how do you deal with this whole
flood of everybody wanting something
from you if we had good advice week we
could have had it we ended up being very
lucky to talk to a couple of filmmakers
that in the dock space just to get their
advice and that was Gary keep it and and
the filmmakers behind Marwan call I've
got a couple other ones yes beings of
pastry to yes and so we basically were
bombarded with lots of opportunity but
you don't I don't know like I guess we
come from the place where we don't
really trust anybody we've made the film
just the two of us and bringing on
people that want to work with you now is
scary it's it's exciting but to see you
you don't want to give up a piece of
what you're doing so we spoke to these
filmmakers to get a sense a lay of the
land like really like who's good who's
not good what should we do what you
think like what do you think we should
do what did you do hope you do different
yeah what would you do different and and
all those sort of things and I think I
wish I would have had a month ago weird
it feels like a year ago I wish had a
bit more perspective on some of these
things I think a lot of people in this
world because Sundance is so it's so big
and it's so quick like it gets announced
in at the beginning of december and then
a month and half later it happens and if
you don't have your business sort of
side or Sundance set up it's a lot of
pressure but these people people are
trying to put you like trying to put you
in a position they're great salespeople
and they want you to make a decision
right away because that's what they're
good at getting people to make a
decision right away on behalf of you um
so that was sort of there was just a lot
of stress yeah yeah in most states
following Sundance we we had or falling
in this Vanessa announcement we had
probably about three four five
conference calls a day to like different
sales agents into communities and there
was kind of like this overarching fusing
with a lot of these people that
if you don't make a decision quickly
you're going to blow it no you're going
to absolutely blow it and it's your one
chance in you know you gotta sign with
us really quickly because time's
a-wastin you know with it wasn't that
strong arm but that was kind of the
sentiment of it and we ended up going
with people that didn't talk that way
because that's just kind of we're pretty
practical pragmatic people and we just
knew that wasn't really the case but
there's like this this overarching
pressure that I think is somewhat real
but also somewhat fabricated AB because
this whole I don't know this whole
experience that the whole movie is about
people who are empowered by technology
empowered by self distribution and
that's the how we started this this well
you know we were empowered by doing it
ourselves and we did absolutely
everything up until that point ourselves
so we were kind of going into all these
conversations thinking you know we know
that we can do X number of things
ourselves and that will lead to you know
why results hopefully what can these
people offer us that we can't do
ourselves and the best advice that we
got were from other filmmakers that you
know told us you know basically like you
can do a lot of this yourselves like
these some of these people can take you
places you can't go and you'll benefit
from but a lot of it you know you don't
necessarily need them like you can make
calls and you can make deals yourselves
but you know so it was really that would
be my biggest piece of advice is find
other filmmakers that have been through
it and just ask them questions because
people people like to share like we like
to share and we know that you know next
year or the gears after that we'll
happily tell anybody you know who listen
like you are in the similar experience
or similar situations like what we went
through yeah yeah i guess like kind of
filmmakers and realize that you have
time to make a decision and you don't
need to sign anything right away and
everything isn't as urgent as
everybody's telling you it is urgent but
is theirs but not that urgent yeah
interesting yeah so it sounds like that
was the way you did sort of the gut
check as to who was legit and who wasn't
was how urgent was their pitch and in
slowing them down you kind of shook out
all sort of the snake oil sales people
something yeah interesting yeah I think
yeah but it is it is it like it is a
fast timeline like getting like it we
just really have no idea like what is
all involved in going into Sundance like
we just we didn't know there's like you
like the schedule at Sundance is
overwhelming like it it's incredible but
it's looking at it right now makes me
tired but it's so exciting at the same
time because this is what we've been
working for for so long so it's like I
almost laughed with my friends the other
day like people get married they feel
like they have attention in some ways
and and going to send us to me is like a
big wedding every day over and over and
over again we are on the line with 2012
sundance film makers james sworsky and
liz empezo they're indie film indie game
the movie premieres in five days on
january twentieth and and let's go back
a little bit are in our let's I guess
dive a little bit deeper into what is it
exactly that you to do every day to
become better storytellers and
filmmakers yeah I don't know what
specific we do but I knew it was really
important we did kind of keep on working
we just keep on making stuff like for
the past eight years maybe almost ten
years actually I've been doing corporate
work and Levin has been doing stuff with
me for five years now but before that
shoes at CBC broadcasting stuff and a
lot of times if we were doing these gigs
and we were doing these contracts that
you know work ideal you know like they
weren't exactly what you wanted to be
doing but they were work they were work
and it got you you know using the camera
telling the story or make it a point you
know using using video and film and we
just turned out a lot of stuff some of
the bad this is some of a good a lot of
it that actually and it's just the past
10 years it's been like just an
evolution of projects you know like each
project is it a little bit bigger than
the last and a little more ambitious and
you get better with each and every one
and like it got to a point like I it's
weird I haven't
picked up a camera because it's doing
this movie for about five months yeah
there's a little little chute in between
there and that is like I'm going through
withdrawal like I'm shaking like because
over the past ten years I would be
shootin like almost every every week or
almost every second week doing at the
project and it was just a huge a volume
of work that just kind of led and
evolved into this point of where it felt
right to do this movie I think we were
pretty lucky in terms of when we got
into filmmaking and making videos and I
worked in television we came out when
digital cameras like the ol you know the
video i used to say old cameras like
this like a like like video was
absolutely the type of cameras were
available to you like pd-1 fifties and
things like that and we were able to
shoot and edit on like that that reality
existed when i started in video when I
was like 18 and that it was amazing that
you could shoot and edit something
yourself because only a few years
earlier like even working in
broadcasting you couldn't shoot on the
FX camera and you couldn't work in like
in you know the jobs are really
segregated in that sort of world but in
the reality that we came up and you
could do everything yourself and I think
that's been really useful and that was
volume yeah and just let us to do lots
of different things like the cameras
that we use have changed and her
processes changed a bit we still use
Final Cut Pro but it was just done a lot
like there's a lot of different ways I
think to get into filmmaking working
through like working on big productions
working your way up and and you know and
working on future films or big
television shows and we didn't do that
we just made stuff on our own over and
over and over again until they got
better and i wouldn't i would recommend
that to anybody who wants to to get into
filmmaking or video or television is
just to make stuff it's so exciting now
that you can make stuff and put it off
and put it out on vimeo and get feedback
from other people making stuff before
you would have to you know go around and
film festivals with your short film to
try to reach out to people and to
improve on what you're doing now you can
you can make stuff on your own in a very
low cost you just have you just need the
time to do it and to be able to get that
online feedback is awesome yeah yeah and
it actually go back to like this really
big like a lot of like the commercial
stuff was telling stories that we didn't
necessarily want to tell uh if you wait
like like telling like stories you know
like where you know it wasn't our
personal story but it was being forced
to work with someone else's message and
do a really good job of it and that
practice that actually led to you know
this wonderful skill set that once you
did have that story that you wanted to
personally tell you knew how to tell it
you were just a better story James is
saying is we've dealt with a lot of
boring topics yes and it's highly unlike
not very visual thing to try to create
programming at it like we've done we've
done things from my construction to like
the breeding of Holstein cows like it's
all over the place and stuff that we've
done and I think we we feel confident
now or we just began to feel confident
when we started the film where we could
make something out of nothing and and
then once it got stuck you can make
something out of this great in the last
two years are you doing a lot of
creative stuff or more administrative
work replying to emails you know is some
of that creativity sort of been on the
back burner a little bit because now
you're doing more sort of the work of a
marketer or of an agent or something
we've been doing the creative staff in
the producing in the marketing
simultaneously we started shooting we we
launched the project in May 2010 we were
shooting all of our like basically
trying to like build up a war chest of
money so that we could actually take
some time off to make the film up until
September then we shot until we were on
the road for three bullets through four
months came back did a little more
editing in early 2011 and basically
we're editing and shooting up until the
summer and all simultaneously we were
trying to like release clips we're
releasing
but from the very beginning cutting
staff you order student pre-orders
answering every single it was really
important as to like engage audience
really early and to engage them well so
we answered every single email that we
got we've gotten bad at that lately yeah
now it's getting a little overwhelming
but we still do try to do as much
because when we dancer every every
Twitter mention you know every facebook
post everything and yeah so it was kind
of like this whole holistic approach of
making the movie and then also promoting
the movie at the same time because it's
kind of funny it's led to this weird
little thing online where people feel
that this movie has been in the works
for ever and it hasn't it's actually
been like 19 months from you know our
first started production to actually
delivering it so it's really actually a
pretty you know that's a nice tight
timeline but not bad at all but online
it seems like they've been hearing about
this movie for forever in when you're
online it's like dog years you know like
it's like one year is actually seven so
feel like this is in like avatar demo
time but its eyes it so did it's funny
yeah that's kind of been our experience
apart but everybody's been great about
it you know you know we can certainly
relate to trying to get back to as many
tweets and as many emails
open because we were putting out extra
segments throughout the production it
was actually actually really creatively
motivating because like we could have
made this and not revealed like a
trailer anything until we were done but
because we were able to sort of try
things out through these sort of web
pieces and in in it also you know helps
build an audience it was just it was
great to get that feedback it is
validating it shows that we were kind of
on the right track and producing stuff
that people wanted to see because we
would put out these pieces that were
reflective of they weren't from the
actual film but they're reflective of
kind of the you know tone and themes
that we were approaching liquid film and
people responded really really
positively to that and that just kind of
showed us that we're on the right track
for sure yeah and the pieces are
excellent you know it's easy to kind of
just go from one right into the next you
know they're all well produced blue
beautifully shot the music you know you
guys talked about you know kind of
working for someone else for so long and
then being able to sort of break off and
do this project what what really enabled
you to get behind this project because
that's what we're all trying to do we're
all trying to leave whatever world were
in and go into the creative world what
does enabled you guys to do that uh I
think well you know you make you take
risks when you like change what you're
doing I was working at CBC for six years
and that was a risk for me to leave and
start doing our own stuff and our own
stuff was we did some small TV series
stuff and we did a lot of corporate
videos and that was a bit of a risk and
then that's sure to grow and that's sure
to become more comfortable working for
other people and we were getting to a
point where we felt really good about it
and we started to make the money that we
wanted to make and some stuff to take on
this project and I think like back a
year and a half ago we just had this
confidence that it was going to be good
and not everyone realized not everybody
saw it saw what we saw in it but we knew
that the content was really exciting and
the stories of the people were amazing
and these guys were inspiring themselves
like they are like you know a lot of
people that are likely listening to this
there you know one or two people working
on projects that they're incredibly
passionate about
they're achieving amazing success to the
internet and watching them was like
watching what we hoped to be like we
were shooting with them and then six
months later we hope to be where they
were at or we could relate to the people
that they were going through so i think
the content was really motivating but we
saved a lot of money to do this we did a
lot of work we kind of killed ourselves
like trying to get everything done so
that we could start the project so we
saved a lot of money the Kickstarter was
a giant motivation having you know
hundreds of people online give you money
on a project that you hadn't really
started that was hugely motivating and
really validating that there'd be an
audience there for it in the end and I
think that's probably a huge factor for
us sort of giving up an income the past
year to do this yeah I'm wondering to
what parallels do you see between the
indie gaming world and the independent
filmmaking world in in terms of the the
world sort of at large and then also
with the artists in each of the world
what are some of the parallels that you
see oh yeah it was it was uncanny
actually it was one of the things that
drew us to this project was that we
thought so much of our own experiences
in these guys yep because it basically
were two people using very accessible
technology working up something by
ourselves at home on our computers and
they are teams of one or two people out
with very accessible technology working
on their vision and then releasing it to
the world and it it was completely you
know like this similar similar vibe and
it's a both industry seemed to ya like
like I think the creative experience is
very similar like the the what you when
you like we're doing a doc so we're not
necessarily creating a whole world for
capturing the world but there's all
these decisions and thoughts and values
and stuff that you put into it and it's
incredibly personal film even though
it's not about us it's about four other
people and they that's the same thing
that they were putting into their games
like they were making decisions
decisions and choices as a way to reach
out to people and share their story
through their games
all their games are about things like
cubes of meat and you know like little
guys with hats but it is there it seemed
right and weird but they are very
personal games and they're trying to be
understood and help other people
understand them through that so the
creative experience is similar the sort
of the market conditions that were both
in are similar but exciting about what
the world of any games is that it feels
like they have massive audiences like
it's incredible the kind of feedback and
fan base that these guys have you know
you may not know you guys may not know
Edmund and Tommy and Phil and and John
but in the video game world and in that
space they're rock stars there yeah
they've got you know there's people that
like every time they say something it
becomes a new story in the gaming world
and they have such big followings and it
is incredible the sort of world that
exists and we get into that in the film
it's a little different than indie film
I think in that respect because there is
this online fan audience you know so in
that would not regard in that regard
which of the which artists have a better
shot at sustaining their careers gamers
or filmmakers I think it's anybody that
can make money at what they do and fund
their next project really I think it is
either or you know and yet yeah I was go
ahead go ahead James oh no go ahead yeah
I was at the green well I'm wondering
with these developers do they have day
jobs outside of like some project that
they'll work on hoping that it catches
on or I mean how does that all work some
do as the developers in the film don't
they like to create a game like the
games that they're making that are
released on xbox and steam and ps3 and
Wii and stuff it like it when you're two
people making a game like if you're two
people making a film it's
all-encompassing and yeah so all these
guys are sacrificing you know working at
a bigger company making two hundred
thousand dollars a year as
programmer to make their own game so
they're in sort of the same boat in
terms of having to you know get rid of
that stable income to do what you want
to do yeah and I think to do anything
that incredibly personal and incredibly
well done it it just takes you over and
it seems for a lot of these games like
just having that day job just doesn't
seem like an option just because you
have two decade dedicate your life to it
yeah it just yet doesn't seem to be an
option hmm we wouldn't know anything
about that are some of these people
living off credit cards I mean to tease
me to sustain themselves or they are
they doing that or are they able to eke
out a little bit of money and maybe get
an upfront deposit or something how do
they it it's all personal risk it's all
it's all like credit cards and only you
know living off of ten thousand dollars
for you know for years it's that's in
that book we see in the film is being a
massive sacrifices they make to get
there their stories out through their
game and you know like they could have
potentially gotten publishers and
advanced feels or or that sort of thing
but they wanted to make their own vision
and not necessarily have anybody to
answer to and that's the risk you have
to take to do it in the same way that we
did have all the Kickstarter people but
it's not like we had a creative saying
what we were doing you know we just had
a responsibility so we have a
responsibility to give them a good film
but that's the same position that we're
in we could have taken on investors
earlier on but we didn't want to we
didn't really need to yeah you didn't
yeah because we own the equipment and it
we own the skill set we didn't need to
hire anyone so the actual costs were
pretty low and that's the thing with
independent development like you you
just need a computer and your brilliant
mind in a great vision and that's kind
of that's enough to get you started and
I I know in talking to Edmund what if
his secrets to success there's like you
asked him like how he did this he's like
I'm really good at being poor you want
to be an independent over you need to be
okay with it and now he's a millionaire
yeah definitely be okay with like living
in that one room apartment
and eating ramen noodles for a long long
time and not having that guarantee of
success and as long as you're okay with
that you'll you'll be fine because you
know you'll make your game and it will
be what it will be and you'll get it out
there yeah I love that i'm just
wondering though how do they sort of
compartmentalize that stress because for
me money stress is like one of the war
stresses that there are but I I totally
get that being kind of you know saving
up and having a cushion and but how do
they sort of compartmentalize was there
were there parts of the film that showed
them stressing out about money and not
knowing where it is incredible stressful
existence and we would attest to that as
well yeah I don't think I think there is
compartmentalization like I don't think
I don't think they do separate it from
the experience I think it's all this one
big lump of experience lump of like
creative experience financial stressors
everything like it's not it's just this
big messy creative experience possessed
anxiety okay yeah yeah no it yeah I wish
it was easier okay I wish it would be
easier and and I think you know in
history artists have had patrons and
stuff like that and been able to do
their own stuff that doesn't exist
anymore or as much so um yeah it like it
and we are on the line with indie game
the movie filmmakers lizanne pezzo and
James sworsky um can you guys take us a
little bit into your production process
you know because we love the look of
everything we see that you guys do you
know for instance we've been talking
about Santa Cruz a little bit what was
that shoot like you know did you meet
with the game developer first and then
go and shoot footage around the pier you
know and then in terms of the interview
like how long do you set up the lighting
and frame the composition for the
interview and how long he's sitting down
for so you can take us a little bit to
the process yeah um I think going into
that she's probably about three weeks
before the key you know we did like a
telephone pre-interview and you know
we're careful enough they're going to
details and that we know what we're
talking about so that we know that
at their story there and now he feels it
about doing the interview but not to go
into too much detail as to you know have
them tell you your entire life story on
it and then kind of feel like they're
repeating themselves once you do get to
get to do and then so when we got to
santa cruz you were sitting in edmonton
Danell but known department and Tommy
left me partner was out of there too and
it was a yeah yeah so we got there and
as soon as you get there you're
completely invading the private space in
a way like they're very cool about it
they're very awesome people but you're
you're like living with them because
there's nowhere to go so we tried to
keep lighting at a minimum minimum and
we shot using Canon 5d Mark tues and
those things can do remarkable things
with very little light so a lot of it I
think the majority of the stuff that we
shot interview wise for Santa Cruz was
one key light and then just kind of
using either the window as a fill I
can't remember how wet but i think we
used the window actually was the key
light and then we just kind of build it
in and then yeah so we would go in and
we shot a interviews with them but we
shot interviews for two days so we
interviewed I think Edmonds for four
hours Tom me for a couple hours and
interviewed the two of them together
over two days we interviewed the wife
and then we shot them working and we
shot his wife working we also did some
scenes outside and Santa Cruz it didn't
actually make it into the film of them
out and about in Santa Cruz we would
shoot exteriors James would wake up at
like five in the morning to get Don
shots we'd also get shots you know and
that's when sort of the magic hour at
the end of the day the whole experience
would have been for five days and that
was basically got us our first test
piece which was five minutes and in a
lot of it is very similar and then when
we got into like actually following
action and following drama there was a
lot of pre-planning
as much as it sounds weird to say that
when you're following you know something
the moment there's a lot of pre-planning
going into when you're going to
interview them when you're going to
interview and ask certain questions just
so that you know cinematically you're
asking different questions and different
scenes and then sometimes it doesn't
work out techny defense it you just have
to work with it as is yeah yeah and like
every every shoot had a shot list that
we hope to get and every shoot had you
know Q and a list of sentiments that we
hope to get to capture and we usually
got what we wanted but there was always
always stuff that would pop up and
surprise us or we there's always stuff
that we couldn't get and there were
always it's weird like so many shots
that I thought were throw away shops
when I was filming them just because I
had extra time ends up making the film
is so easy yeah yeah the shooting more
is better totally and yeah and then you
know things like all the surprises like
hopefully you guys will see the film one
is done funny like thing you have this
amazing feeling when things that you
didn't expect happen it's an incredible
filmmaking experience to be witnessing
something totally unexpected and it
makes the movie all that much better
something amazing ride and ah I feel
what it must be like to be in their
shoes just to have this like flood of
just some emails and opportunities we've
been speaking with the minds and
creators behind indie game the movie
lays on a show and James sworsky and if
you are attending Sundance next week
make sure to check the site for the
various showings it has a number of
showings and we kind of said before we
came on the air we were going to sort of
live out the Sunday's experience through
you guys you guys are certainly able to
do that for us and much much more it's
been such a pleasure having you guys
join us on film cars today and and I
just don't see how any independent
filmmaker I don't see how you can get by
this year without seeing this film I'm
dying to see it yeah I am typically I'll
have to see this one so that that's our
sort of like that's our call to action
as our call to action everyone listening
you gotta see the
smoov-e and you can hear that lizette
lizanne and James are very accessible
you can find them on Twitter at indie
game the moot at indie game movie Lee's
ampas oh and James sworsky check check
their website to find out how to spell
the names yeah in the folks the website
is indie game the movie calm and also on
facebook.com / indie game the movie
we're wishing you guys the best this
week at Sundance oh and we're looking
forward to all the good things we're
going to hear and we certainly
appreciate you guys taking the time
today especially in this time crunch
when you have so much going on yeah
thanks so much ya know happy to do it
thanks for having us on yeah thank you
so much it's great oh absolutely thank
you you guys are the best you know I
feel like this is part one I feel I feel
like we depart to come in we left a lot
of questions on the table on the table I
really want to find out more you know
but you know what job you know and if
you know if Sunday's doesn't take you
into a whole new realm and if you're
still up for it would love to get you
back on post Sundance so for part two
that's Mary ya know we loved it alright
alright and a big shout out to our guy
Ronan rosner he put in a ton of overtime
this week on film courage calm so we
certainly appreciate your efforts Ronan
thank you so much yes thank you Ronan
next week we will be joined by the
vicious brothers Colin minahan and
Stuart Ortiz we will talk to them about
their film grave encounters which world
premiered at tribeca in 2011 as well as
their love for paranormal subject matter
and more for more info on this 25-year
old filmmaking duo please visit the
vicious brothers calm and thank you
again for hanging out with us until next
Sunday have a great week
you